sí
[Música]
imaginas un país que regala las plantas
con agua salada un país que haya
conseguido transformar un árido y
estéril desierto en frondosos campos de
cultivo o un país que situado en uno de
los lugares más áridos y secos de la
tierra haya sido capaz de hacerse con un
suministro casi ilimitado de agua pues
queridos amigos amigas no se trata de
ningún espejismo ese lugar existe gran
parte de su territorio se asienta sobre
los desiertos de négev y de judea y su
nombre es israel hablamos del único país
de todo el planeta tierra que hoy tiene
menos superficie de desierto que hace 50
años por si fuera poco cada año el país
exporta más de 2 mil millones de dólares
en productos agrícolas sobre todo
productos frescos como frutas y
vegetales y esto es exactamente sobre lo
que os vamos a hablar en este vídeo
sobre cómo israel ha sido capaz de
convertir al mismo desierto en todo un
vergel sobre cómo este país ha superado
la escasez del agua
por cierto apunte este vídeo lo hemos
preparado gracias a la comunidad de
patria allí es donde se escogió
precisamente este tema así que está
especialmente dedicado a todos los que
nos apoyáis en patrón arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
un informe confidencial del consejo
nacional de inteligencia de los eeuu
publicado en 2012 y más tarde
desclasificado parcialmente apunta a una
futura crisis hídrica una enorme crisis
del agua a nivel mundial según este
informe el consumo de agua se situaría
por encima de cualquier parámetro
sostenible cada vez somos más y cada vez
gastamos más agua consumimos más carne
tenemos más jardines más piscinas y
consumimos más energía
todo ello son cosas que podéis creerme
requieren de muchísima agua por ejemplo
producir un kilo tan solo un kilo de
carne consume 10 y 7 veces más agua que
producir un kilo de maíz de esta forma
el informe coincidía con otras
informaciones de expertos en que más del
20 por ciento de la población mundial
más de 1500 millones de personas sufrían
y mucho con esta crisis hídrica durante
las próximas décadas 1500 millones de
personas que tendrán serios pero que muy
serios problemas para acceder a un
suministro regular de agua hablamos
amigos de una crisis que pondría en
jaque a todo el sistema alimentario
mundial y que no penséis ni por un
instante que se limitaría a castigar a
los países más pobres por ejemplo el
valle de san joaquín en california el
centro el corazón de la agricultura de
calidad californiana podría desaparecer
al menos tal y como lo conocemos y eso
eso es lo que ha hecho que en este vídeo
nos hagamos una pregunta y estamos a
casos condenados a no tener suficiente
agua pues queridos amigos amigas creo
que ha llegado el momento de echar un
vistazo a uno de los lugares más áridos
y armas de todo el planeta
[Música]
ni más ni menos que el 60% del
territorio israelí está cubierto por el
desierto lo que explica que la relación
de este pueblo con el agua sea tan
estrecha que está presente
constantemente ya sea en la cultura la
política o incluso en la religión
derecho una de las oraciones judías más
conocidas semana advierte que el castigo
por no cumplir los mandamientos de dios
será precisamente que la lluvia dejará
de caer a pesar de ello tal y como
seguramente todos sepáis israel es un
país próspero un importante exportador
agroalimentario y tiene un suministro
abundante y garantizado de agua de hecho
incluso les suministra agua a sus
vecinos así que la pregunta la gran
pregunta que podemos hacernos es cómo
demonios han logrado superar la escasez
del agua que podemos aprender de ellos
nos enfrentamos a un futuro con agua o
con sed en este vídeo os vamos a
responder a todas estas preguntas pero
antes antes tenemos que empezar por el
principio tenemos que ver un poquito de
historia
[Música]
arterias de israel
a finales de los años 20 los economistas
que asesoraban al gobierno británico que
en aquel momento era quien controlaba
este territorio afirmaron que la
inmigración de más judíos a palestina no
era sostenible y no lo era porque según
sus cálculos los recursos hídricos eran
tan limitados que era imposible que
pudieran vivir más de dos millones de
personas tirando por lo alto sí lo sé
hoy viven más de 12 millones ya sabéis
las previsiones el caso es que desde ese
preciso momento las organizaciones
judías de la zona entendieron pues que
su futuro pasaba por incrementar los
recursos hídricos tenían que encontrar
agua a toda costa para los campos de
cultivo para los nuevos colonos que
pudieran llegar y para poder construir
un nuevo israel
[Música]
pero había un problema la mayor parte
del país era desértico árido y seco los
recursos hídricos disponibles se
concentraban en el norte pero los judíos
estaban estableciendo mayoritariamente
en torno a la nueva gran urbe de la
región tel aviv situada en el centro del
país así que para resolver este embrollo
tras la publicación del informe
británico en 1939 le encargaron uno de
los ingenieros hidráulicos más reputados
del país sin jaulas un inmigrante polaco
que diseñará un plan hídrico ni más ni
menos que el plan que tenía que
garantizar el futuro de israel
[Música]
y sabéis que dicho y hecho eso fue
exactamente lo que hizo haciendo gala de
todo su ingenio y atrevimiento el señor
blas diseñó un plan de tres fases
prácticamente el plan que se ejecutó
durante décadas y que hizo posible el
despegue demográfico y económico de
israel veréis la primera fase que
consistía en la extracción de agua
mediante perforaciones profundas el
señor blas estaba convencido de que bajo
el subsuelo de israel incluso en zonas
tan áridas como el desierto del néguev
había agua así que se propuso
encontrarla para abastecer nuevos
establecimientos agrícolas claro que
incluso de tener éxito esa operación no
sería suficiente el país tenía que
aprovechar hasta la última gota que
hubiera disponible es decir tenían que
conseguir trasladar el agua desde donde
era relativamente abundante hasta donde
hacía falta exactamente por eso las dos
siguientes fases respondieron
precisamente a esta idea
[Música]
la segunda fase tenía como objetivo
bombear agua desde el río jordán el río
más importante de la región hasta el
sureste llegando incluso hasta el
mismísimo desierto del néguev fue una
zona inhabilitada en la cual los nuevos
colonos podrían instalarse y hacer
crecer sus campos de cultivo
pero con mucha muchísima diferencia la
parte más importante del plan fue la
tercera fase la construcción del
acueducto nacional hablamos de un enorme
trasvase de más de 100 kilómetros que
tenía que trasladar agua desde el norte
del país especialmente desde el mar de
galilea el lado de agua dulce más grande
del país hasta donde hiciera falta
conectando además los recursos
desarrollados en las fases anteriores en
otras palabras lo que el señor blas
propuso fue un enorme plan de inversión
para construir las arterias de israel
esto es un enorme sistema hídrico que
logrará garantizar el acceso al agua
dulce a lo largo y ancho de todo el país
y ojo porque si algo estaba claro es que
poner en marcha este plan era algo muy
pero que muy urgente fijaos
[Música]
en el día de la declaración de
independencia del estado hebreo el 14 de
mayo de 1948 israel tenía 800 6000
habitantes prácticamente en los
siguientes tres años llegaron al país
700 mil personas más evidentemente la
mayor parte de ellas procedentes del
viejo continente para atender de repente
a tantas personas alimentarlas y lograr
que encontrarse en un trabajo para
subsistir hacía falta mucha muchísima
agua de esta forma las restricciones de
agua se volvieron cada vez más exigentes
y poner en marcha el plan de sin jaulas
era algo de máxima urgencia
el problema es que hacía falta mucho
dinero y no estamos hablando de un país
precisamente rico por aquel entonces por
no hablar de que los pocos recursos de
los que disponía el nuevo gobierno
israelí pues iban a parar en gran medida
a la seguridad y la defensa entonces la
pregunta es cómo hacerlo pues fue justo
aquí cuando el por aquel entonces primer
ministro de israel bng unión tomó una de
las decisiones más polémicas de toda la
historia de israel una decisión que pudo
incluso terminar desembocando en todo un
conflicto civil
[Música]
a comienzos de la década de los 50 ben
gurión aceptó firmar un acuerdo de
reparación con la república federal
alemana de conrad adenauer un acuerdo
por el que el estado de israel recibió
una indemnización de tres mil millones
de marcos como compensación por los
crímenes nazis y el robo y la
destrucción de propiedades judías
durante los tiempos del tercer reich
fue algo tremendamente impopular a
aceptar una compensación por tantísimo
dolor muchos israelíes sintieron que se
estaba comprando su dolor que se estaba
mercantilizando con uno de los sucesos
más trágicos de la historia de la
humanidad hubo protestas manifestaciones
enfrentamientos violentos con las
fuerzas de seguridad y al final la
knesset el parlamento israelí aprobó el
acuerdo por tan solo dos votos de
diferencia
a pesar de todo ya había dinero el
trasvase del río jordán se completó en
1955 y durante los siguientes años el
país se puso literalmente patas arriba
el acueducto nacional supuso construir
tuberías canales y pequeños embalses por
toda la geografía nacional la propia red
principal tenía que ser básicamente
subterránea y ser capaz de soportar
cualquier ataque que se pudiera producir
trabajaron miles y miles de personas en
esta inmensa obra y el gasto per cápita
fue mayor que el del mismísimo canal de
panamá pero finalmente en 1964 el
acueducto nacional fue una realidad el
suministro de agua estaba por fin
garantizado en todo el país
amigos sin esta inmensa obra podemos
decir que el enorme crecimiento
económico y demográfico que israel ha
experimentado simple y llanamente no
hubiera sido posible ahora bien hoy
israel tiene más de 9 millones de
habitantes y una economía moderna así
que hacía falta hacer más mucho más
[Música]
israel necesita más agua
con el comienzo del siglo 21 los
problemas con el suministro de agua
volvieron a estar una vez más sobre la
mesa y fue aquí cuando se puso en marcha
toda una nueva revolución y es que
veréis en 2006 se tomó la decisión de
transferir la gestión del sistema de
agua desde el nivel político al nivel
tecnocrático esto es los políticos
dejaron de estar al frente y se creó la
autoridad del agua de israel una agencia
cuya misión pues es gestionar el sistema
de forma profesional y vaya si lo
hicieron en 2008 esta autoridad del agua
tomó una decisión muy pero que muy
controvertida todo el mundo tendría que
pagar el precio real que costaba a
suministrar el agua hasta ese momento
tal y como ocurre en la mayor parte de
países del mundo pues el precio del agua
estaba subvencionado por el gobierno la
gente entiende que el agua es un tesoro
pero no comprende por qué tiene que
pagarla en la lluvia y creen que el agua
es gratis y tienen razón ese agua es
gratis pero el agua segura confiable y
siempre disponible no es gratis y no
puede serlo la construcción de
infraestructuras no es gratis miembro de
alto rango de la autoridad del agua de
israel la medidad tenía dos objetivos
muy claros por un lado impulsar el
ahorro de agua ya sabes si tienes que
pagar más puedes gastar
- y por otro incrementar los ingresos
del sistema para poder así construir más
infraestructuras y mejorar su
mantenimiento pero eso eso no fue todo
[Música]
esta agencia también le retira a los
ayuntamientos el control de la
distribución del agua y la gestión de
las aguas residuales a cambio que un
sistema de 55 empresas municipales que
tenían que funcionar con criterios de
mercado para gestionar toda la red el
dinero recaudado ya no iría a los
presupuestos municipales sino a mejorar
el sistema por ejemplo a evitar las
bocas de agua de las tuberías que muchas
ciudades supone perder más del 30% de
todo el agua y que en israel está muy
por debajo del 10%
además de esta forma si un alcalde pues
quiere regar los parques municipales ya
no tiene agua gratis para hacerlo tiene
que pagar el precio real la medida
amigos fue un completo y rotundo éxito
sin tener que limitar el suministro el
consumo de agua residencial pública y
privada cayó casi un 20 por ciento en
todo el país por ejemplo en los parques
y jardines pues se sustituyeron muchas
plantas por otras mejor adaptadas a la
zona que consumían menos agua y luego en
la agricultura pues pasó tres cuartas
partes de lo mismo
y eso no es todo para impulsar la
innovación en materia del agua el
gobierno estableció planes de apoyo a la
inversión en innovación de estas nuevas
empresas líder a convertir las ciudades
israelíes en auténticos laboratorios del
agua las empresas compiten por los
fondos al tiempo que las innovaciones
les permiten mejorar su hoja de
resultados
[Música]
y así así es exactamente como se venció
de nuevo a la sequía durante los
primeros años de este siglo 21 pero
sabéis que aún no hemos terminado porque
una cosa es evitar la sequía y otra muy
distinta tener todo el agua que quieras
y además convertirlo en un gran negocio
y eso eso es exactamente lo que israel
ha conseguido atentos
en el ingenio está la clave
amigos israel es un país conocido por
tres cosas el mossad la eficacia de sus
fuerzas armadas y también la innovación
de hecho es conocido como la startup
nation y en el caso de la gestión del
agua que es toda una prioridad nacional
pues no iba a ser diferente
especialmente en el campo de la
agricultura que al fin y al cabo supone
el 55 por ciento de todo el consumo de
agua de israél y si fue precisamente en
este país donde se produjo una de las
grandes revoluciones agrícolas de las
últimas décadas el riego por goteo una
técnica que permita ahorrar hasta el 60
por ciento del agua al tiempo que mejora
el rendimiento de los cultivos
hablamos de una técnica que consiste en
regar una planta gota a gota
directamente a la raíz y que en los
últimos años ha sido mejorada con el
conocido como fertirriego esto es un
riego por goteo en el que se incluye
también gota a gota los fertilizantes e
incluso con el nutrir diego él no va más
de la tecnología agrícola en este caso
por ejemplo mediante el riego por goteo
se suministra todo lo que las plantas
necesitan para crecer de tal forma que
incluso se pueden desarrollar enormes
plantaciones sobre la mismísima arena
del desierto con el útil riego los
cultivos crecen en cualquier lado la
arena del desierto se puede utilizar
para mantener la planta en su lugar y el
agua con nutrientes es administrar
por el riego por goteo que se encarga
del resto racimo jordán e incluso ahora
están introduciendo diminutos
dispositivos que se colocan en las
raíces y detectan cuando hay que regar
exactamente las plantas pues bien el
caso es que todas estas tecnologías han
sido desarrolladas sobre todo por
empresas israelíes pero ahí ahí tampoco
queda todo otro campo en el que los
israelíes son especialmente buenos y en
el de las semillas tanto de las semillas
tradicionales como de las modificadas
genéticamente algo que les ha permitido
por ejemplo reducir el consumo de agua
de cada planta e incluso atentos han
desarrollado semillas que se pueden
regar con agua ligeramente salada como
es el agua salobre que es un tipo de
agua de la que hay menor cantidad en el
subsuelo de todo oriente medio pero que
siempre se pensó pues que no valía para
nada si si tal cual como lo escucháis en
israel podéis encontrar a dos con
melones tomates pimientos o yo que se
berenjenas entre otras muchas clases de
frutas y verduras que son regadas con
una mezcla de agua dulce y agua salada y
aún aún hay más
[Música]
junto a la infraestructura ligada al
acueducto nacional durante los últimos
años este país ha desarrollado una
segunda infraestructura para repartir
las aguas residuales depuradas por todo
el país de tal forma que ni más ni menos
que el 85% de todas ellas se reutilizan
para que pues básicamente para la
agricultura y también para regar por
ejemplo parques o campos de golf
no hay nada parecido en el resto del
mundo y para colmo israel también se ha
convertido en uno de los líderes
mundiales en la tecnología de la
desalinización de hecho una de las
mayores plantas por volumen y eficacia
de todo el planeta se encuentra
precisamente en el entorno de 'the life
la planta sobre que es capaz de procesar
más de 600 millones de litros de agua al
día y así de esta forma es como israel
ha vencido a las sequías que llevan
azotando esta región del mundo desde
hace milenios israel un país enclavado
en un terreno seco y árido hoy tiene
todo el suministro de agua que pueda
necesitar e incluso le suministra agua
para destina y también a jordania todo
lo ha conseguido mediante la ingeniería
la innovación y también el sistema de
precios pero llegados hasta aquí turno
para ti qué te parece la apuesta de
israel por el agua crees que es el
camino a seguir para evitar una crisis
hídrica déjanos por aquí abajo tu
respuesta en los comentarios y ya sabéis
si este vídeo ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle al botón de like y
antes de terminar muchas gracias a todos
los que nos apoyáis en patria espero que
este vídeo que vosotros mismos habéis
escogido os haya gustado un saludo y
hasta la próxima
[Música]